[Música]
y llegó el momento de repasar la prensa
internacional con rosa pérez más euros a
bienvenida a feliz martes muy buen día y
vamos a abrir entonces con lo que
estábamos avanzando al principio en
nuestro programa con eeuu y la noticia
ya confirmada por la casa blanca sobre
la intención del presidente joe biden de
revalidar su mandato y aquí a tres años
empezamos entonces con the hills the
shield vaivén pretende presentarse a la
reelección de 1024 dice aquí el texto es
de brad samples
exacto y raúl este texto lo que hace
referencia es una polémica que desataron
publicaciones en el 'washington post' y
en el medio político en referencia a las
especulaciones que había dentro del
partido demócrata sobre la posibilidad
de que biden se volviera a presentar en
2024 bien finalmente james aquí la
portavoz de la casa blanca acabando
confirmando las intenciones del actual
presidente y lo que plantea este
artículo es que si bien en las
elecciones primarias demócratas joe
biden se presentó como un candidato de
transición pero también como el mejor
posicionado para donald trump en las
elecciones de 2020 se plantea si es
también la posibilidad de que donald
trump se presente en 2024 lo que podría
empujar a bailén a hacerlo también rosa
ahora vamos con cnn el debate byd en
2024 es un perdedor absoluto para los
demócratas es un análisis del editor
chris cillizza exacto y lo que es lo que
plantea este editor del ascienden es que
bardem no lleva ni tan siquiera un año
en la casa blanca y su partido ya está
fracturado respecto a la cuestión sobre
si vaivén debería representarse uno en
2024 y plantea dos cuestiones
fundamentales en primer lugar que joe
biden va a tener 82 años en 2024 y si
realmente eso le va a permitir volverse
a presentar y por otro lado pregunta
también la candidatura de joe biden en
2024 es la mejor opción para que los
demócratas se queden en la casa blanca
dice sea como sea los demócratas tienen
tiempo para pensar lo que dan todavía
más de tres años pero sin embargo dice
este debate debería pueden mantenerse a
puerta a puerta cerrada no hace ningún
bien exponerla al público así es rosa
bueno seguimos hablando de joe biden
pero ahora la polémica solución para
sortear la crisis energética se titula
el 'washington post' y leo textualmente
más petróleo ahora menos petróleo luego
el mensaje tramposo a bailén sobre la
energía es un artículo que hizo andy
lynch que está pues siga un poco la
polémica sobre el presidente
estadounidense que recordemos mantiene
su popularidad por debajo del 50 por
ciento lo que sucede es que joe biden
como hemos explicado aquí largo y
tendido se erige un poco como líder
mundial en la lucha global contra el
cambio climático pero cuestiones de
política interna le hacen asumir ciertas
contradicciones y lo que sucede ahora es
que con el aumento de los precios de la
energía a joe biden se ve digamos con la
necesidad de ampliar los suministros
energéticos basados en el gas y en el
petróleo además esto se suma a que ha
probado
derechos de prospecciones de petróleo en
el golfo de mexico lo que ha desatado
muchas críticas por parte tanto de la
sociedad civil como de la comunidad
científica o de pues contrincantes
políticos sin embargo la casa blanca
dice que estas acciones a corto plazo
para salir un poco del paso no van a
impedir las proyecciones que tiene la
casa blanca a largo plazo en términos de
políticas climáticas como son recordemos
la promesa de neutralidad de emisiones
para 2050
vamos a ver siempre este delicado
equilibrio de raúl entre el corto y el
largo plazo que nos ha llevado donde
estamos y seguimos con otro tema que
involucra también a eeuu en una larga
disputa hablando de corto y largo plazo
y largo plazo esto con méxico vamos a
ver precisamente 'el universal' empieza
la batalla real dice la cancillería de
méxico ante las respuestas de armerías
de eeuu que pasa lo que sucede es que en
agosto en méxico denunció ante la corte
federal de boston a las principales
empresas de armamento de eeuu por
contribuir de forma aunque sea indirecta
al crimen organizado en méxico ahora
estas empresas han podido
responder y han presentado los
argumentos de su defensa y alegan que no
son rastreables los crímenes causados
por armas extranjeras en méxico y que
estas empresas no tienen la obligación
de hacerse responsables por los crímenes
que pasan en mexico en manos de
delincuentes mexicanos algo a lo que el
gobierno de méxico dice o que es una
respuesta que ya se esperaba y que hay
tiempo para seguir con el litigio méxico
debe presentar una réplica antes de
finales de enero de 2022 y las armerías
tienen hasta finales de febrero para
presentar una contrarréplica rápidamente
vamos un salto a francia con un tema en
relación también con el crimen
internacional la rosa y la organización
de cooperación policial para combatirlo
la interpol liberación o vamos a ir para
allá de ahí que soportaba interpol
policías para la influencia exacta esta
puerta dará esa pues también impactante
y en la versión digital también vemos
varios artículos que se dedican al mismo
tema y es que ésta la organización que
coordina las policías de 194 países debe
elegir un nuevo un nuevo jefe y el que
tiene más posibilidades de llegar al
cargo es un inspector del ministerio de
interior de los emiratos árabes unidos-
que está acusado de torturas tal y como
señala libération se trata de ahmed
naser al racing y lo que defiende este
artículo es que la posibilidad de que
lleve de que llegue a la jefatura de la
organización demuestra el peso que están
adquiriendo los países autoritarios en
el seno de la interpol